avec wolfram bien sûr bonjour hélène
bonjour à la une de la presse
aujourd'hui l'émotion des parlementaires
britanniques hélène auquel le président
ukrainien zelensky s'est adressé hier
dans un discours en vidéoconférence les
bombardements ne nous ont pas brisé nous
ne perdrons pas peu importe le prix nous
nous battrons dans les forêts dans les
champs sur les rivages dans les rues a
lancé volodymyr zelensky citer mot pour
mot par plusieurs quotidiens ce matin
outre manche notamment vip évoque une
adresse churchillienne faisant écho au
discours du premier ministre winston
churchill le 4 juin 1940 cette
intervention pauline a été ovationné par
les parlementaires britanniques qui se
sont levés pour applaudir le président
ukrainien le gratuit métro par le d'un
discours historique au moment même où
l'ukraine se bat pour sa survie
l'ukraine compte déjà plus de 2 millions
de personnes en moins de deux semaines
de conflit essentiellement regroupés
pour le moment dans les pays frontaliers
de l'ouest de l'ukraine la pologne la
slovaquie la hongrie et la roumanie ces
deux millions de réfugiés sont appelés à
être prise en charge tout ou tard par
d'autres pays européens en belgique le
soir dit espérer que bruxelles sera à la
hauteur de ce défi tout en relevant que
l'accueil d'une population étrangère je
cite constitue un moment sensible pour
toute société susceptible de se
transformer en pomme de discorde s'il
n'est pas encadrée en france où le
gouvernement annonce la création d'une
plateforme pour faciliter l'accueil de
ces réfugiés du kenya le quotidien
l'humanité exprime sa solidarité et
appelle ses lectrices et lecteurs
envoyer des dons et des mots pour la
fête en partenariat avec le secours
populaire français
la solidarité l'aide et l'accueil de
tous les réfugiés qui fuient la guerre
l'oppression la misère sont une
nécessité et un devoir d'humanité écrit
le journal d apple d appel à l'accueil
et à la solidarité qui font grincer
quelques dents ailleurs dans le monde on
arabie saoudite pourtant peu réputé pour
son accueil d étrange et le quotidien
officiel arabe nous s'indigne des
préjugés et du deux poids deux mesures
dont les européens feraient preuve
envers les réfugiés le journal et trio
passage pauline les commentaires
entendus à la télévision témoignant
selon lui du racisme désinvolte des
journalistes occidentaux dans leur
couverture de cette guerre en ukraine le
journal cite la responsable de la
division europe de human rights watch
sur le traitement inégalitaire je laisse
site réservé par lieu aux réfugiés
judith sunderland dit observer un
contraste frappant entre la réponse de
l'ue aux réfugiés de craignent à et
celle adressée réservé aux syriens aux
afghans aux irakiens ou aux érythréens
notamment face à la catastrophe
humanitaire en ukraine on en parle dans
le journal les états unis ont annoncé
hier à un embargo sur les hydrocarbures
russes cette décision est saluée par le
wall street journal qui estime que joe
biden a pris la bonne décision mais
qu'il se livre à une contradiction
affolante je cite en décrétant en même
temps une transition à toute vapeur vers
l'énergie verte une décision perçue
comme un assaut contre les hydrocarbures
américains pour lesquels le journal
demande l'abrogation de toutes les
réglementations visant à freiner leur
production leur développement et leur
consommation pour limiter la flambée des
prix dans leur tentative de réduire le
coût de cet embargo les états unis on
l'a évoqué hier se sont adressés au
venezuela mais également aux pays du
golfe selon le guardian ces derniers
auraient refusé eux d'accéder aux
demandes de washington
une fin de non recevoir que le quotidien
britannique attribue explique par le
refroidissement des relations entre ces
pays et les états unis sous
l'administration joe biden en france l
embargo américain sur les hydrocarbures
russes est perçu comme une le site
déclaration de guerre économique envers
moscou une pour libération ce
durcissement du bras de fer avec moscou
fait planer le risque d'un choc
économique sans précédent depuis un demi
siècle il y à là tous les ingrédients
d'une crise d'approvisionnement comme
l'europe n'en a pas connu depuis des
décennies près lacroix qui évoque le
casse tête des européens confrontés à la
nécessité de limiter leur dépendance aux
hydrocarbures russes un dossier qui va
être abordée par les 27 ans lors du
sommet qui est prévue ce jeudi et ce
vendredi à versailles on ne se quittent
pas là-dessus jelen n'a rien de tel
pauline pas vrai qu'un peu de foot
pourquoi changer les idées les fans de
ballon rond en tout cas retiennent leur
souffle avant la rencontre de ce soir je
parle bien sûr du déplacement du psg sur
la pelouse du real madrid pour les
huitièmes de finale retour de la ligue
des champions l'équipe nous apprend et
je sens que ça va vous transporter de
joie que kilian maps et dicky qui va
mieux et qu'il est même d'attac après sa
petite blessure de lundi le journal la
frise déjà la crise d'apoplexie et titre
en toute sobriété temps le retour du
génie avec la police de la guerre des
étoiles un pourvu que ça ne tourne pas à
l'empiré contre attaque paribas on fera
un point demain même heure même endroit
merci beaucoup et l'aisne